il fallait que j'aie un jeu à la hauteur
de ce retour là et regardez c'est très
simple il ya ici des montagnes il y a
des trous à numérotées de 1 à 9 dans le
sac trou il ya ce qu'on appelle une race
ravalant ch c'est à dire une petite
avalanche de nice a excellé dans un trou
c'est le retour du chocolat je vous le
dis on va découvrir le trou numéro 6
castaldi baisser notre masque mais c'est
votre masque attention est ce qu'il y
avait le chocolat dans la 6 3 2 à 0 10
vous n'êtes sauver l'école
belga attention attention il reste deux
trous et dans un des tunnels et chocolat
ça sent pas bon
oui kelly mais novaes lit le banquier
vous propose pas le banquier le moniteur
de ski on propose un échange de ses
charges de ce singe direct vous changez
ne sent pas du tout depuis le début vous
changez jean-michel on vous a proposé de
changer également attention jean mi vous
pouvez laisser votre masque nom complet
pourrait baisser votre masse on va donc
ouvrir le trou numéro 4 pour voir si
c'est le trou chocolatées ou si c'est le
trou avec avalanche tonneinquais qu'elle
immobilise c'est pas gagné 1 - 2 1
je l'espère pour son retour jamais qu'un
jour fouquières ça va calmer je vais
bien merci
alors les chéris le jeu est très très
très très simple il ya ici des poubelles
c'est très simple il va falloir pousser
les poubelles pour être dans la cible là
bas ici trouvez votre binôme
allez-y daniel l'info avec qui allez
vous jouer daniel moreau 1 isabelle
albanie vous êtes sûr que c'est pas
dangereux il ya noël
mais les bombes a repoussé besoin
on sait qu'on attend c'est la chance
d'être sous pression le président
laurent gbagbo
bon bah si vous acceptez jésus vient de
louer à lady le tallec français nicolas
beau là bas c'est simple je ne sens pas
les noms j'en passe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean-michel jean-michel je penserai
qu'il y avait peu de chance nicolas mais
vous avez su aller vous voulez vous
attention à nous on va jouer au
chamboule tennis ce soir c'est très
simple il va falloir dégommer les boîtes
de conserve à l'aide d'une raquette et
du le bal tee shirts attin aller annuel
allez tu perds ses pairs mais j'entends
les gens tucuman enlevé mon alex a vogué
ou doc est là combien y en a combien en
tout elle a 15 ans tout il en reste six
temps qu'il entend lever 9 bravo
guillaume genton après ces mois là
il a fait comme ça d'amener ses actions
j'essaie plus bas il a déjà eu assez
assez assez de malheurs dans sa carrière
derrière sakho doit monter à 50 le redis
par derrière ça ne trompe pas montiel
mais bravo quand même c'est bien
c'était bien tenté un jour me oui c'est
génial
si on joue très bien au tennis et qu à
pernikoff faites attention il a un fou
était alors oui on est bon déjà
[Rires]
finalement rattrapé les cherry on
rappelle que si vous nous rejoignez non
nico tu veux démarrer le jeu démarre
merci les gardes lâcher une pression non
musique sa fenêtre
oui comme créer là c'est bon comme c'est
pas trop fort si elle casser le mur à
gauche à droite on la sait tu perds ton
slip héroïque au clair sur ce site au
milieu matin la faille n'y a aucune
c'est quoi tu perds ton cela dit quand
on sait que tu perds ton temps d'escale
[Musique]